[Music]
welcome back everybody
okay so it's been one week
in the complex wilderness and today i am
ready to tell you about one of my
favorite
properties of complex functions so i'm
going to define what it means for a
function to be analytic
and analytic functions are essentially
well-behaved functions that we can do
calculus on okay so we're used to doing
uh taking derivatives and doing
integrals for real valued functions and
we would like for all of that to carry
over to complex
complex functions because again remember
these complex functions are going to be
how we represent the solutions of
ordinary and partial differential
equations so we need to be able to take
derivatives and integrals and do
calculus
and some functions in the complex plane
are actually pretty wild and poorly
behaved and break our intuition of what
it means to be able to do calculus
so
some functions are better behaved than
others and the well-behaved functions
that we can do calculus on are typically
called analytic functions okay so
specifically we're going to be talking
about
uh analytic
functions okay analytic functions very
very important class especially for
solving partial differential equations
so a function
and i'm going to define it then i'm
going to give you an example of a
non-analytic function to show you how
things get weird and then i'm going to
give you uh conditions to know if a
function is or is not analytic
so a function
let's say f of z
is analytic and i'm going to use red for
this is analytic
and we typically say it's analytic in a
certain region of the complex plane so
uh in
a domain
a domain is just a region it's math
speak for some you know set uh in the
complex plane some domain
d
in the complex plane in the complex
plane it could be equal to the complex
plane it could be the whole plane or it
could be a little subset so if i have
my complex plane
then my domain is just some you know
some little region where i'm talking
about some subset
a function f of z is analytic in that
domain uh d
if
f of z is single valued remember the
logarithm was infinitely valued so if f
of z is single valued
single
valued
like the cosine and sine functions are
single valued z squared is single valued
z to the one half is not single value
there's two solutions to z to the half
if it's single value
and
has a finite derivative
derivative
uh f of z f prime of z
everywhere or let's say for
every
z in that domain d okay this is just
curly d sorry it looks so squiggly
that's my fancy pants d
uh okay so this is just math words and
these are the conditions i'm going to
show you that these are the conditions
for that function f for it to be well
behaved enough for us to do uh calculus
on we can take derivatives and they mean
uh something intuitive to us we can do
integrals in that domain d and there are
special nice properties uh if f is
single valued and
there exists a finite derivative at all
points in that domain so we're talking
about points z
that are inside this domain that's what
this is in math speak z is an element of
the set d
the domain d
uh okay so we already know about
functions that are not single valued z
to the one half has two values z to the
one third has three values
uh log of z has infinitely many values
so those are going to kind of break
immediately this definition of analytic
and calculus is going to be weird or at
least slightly different on those
functions
functions like z squared are going to be
fine
so it has to be single valued and it has
to have a finite derivative for every z
in the domain so
specifically the derivative can't be
infinite it can't be like you know the
function one over z
is going to blow up at z equals zero it
has an infinite derivative
and the derivative is going to have to
be the same no matter what path i take
that derivative in okay so i'll tell you
what that means in a minute
good
uh so this is a kind of the definition
and what i want to do now is i want to
give you an example of a non-analytic
function to show you the kinds of weird
things that can happen in the complex
plane
so a non-analytic function
not analytic
function
would be f of z
equals the complex conjugate of z which
we call z bar
which is equal to the real part minus i
times the imaginary part so instead of x
plus iy which is z
the complex conjugate is x minus iy
and i claim that this function is not
analytic we are not going to be able to
do normal calculus and in fact what i'm
going to show you is that the derivative
doesn't exist uniquely it doesn't have
kind of a unique well-defined derivative
of this function it's a weird function
okay
so let's see uh i think what i want to
actually show you is we're just going to
compute the derivative and i'm going to
show you that weird things happen
so we're going to take
df
dz
and remember
that
the definition of a derivative is
essentially this kind of infinitesimal
rate of change of f as i vary z so this
would be kind of the limit
as delta z goes to
zero so my infinitesimal delta z goes to
zero
of f
of z plus delta z
minus
f of z
divided by delta z okay
this is just standard you know freshman
calculus kind of this is how we always
have to find the derivative this is how
we're going to define the derivative in
the complex plane too totally legit
uh
and so you know that's essentially the
limit
of
let's let's say this is
the limit
as delta z goes to zero
of
z bar
over delta z that's just you know f of z
is um
i'm sorry i should have said
ah this is
delta
delta z bar delta z bar over delta z you
can convince yourself that if you plug
in um
z plus delta z
to z bar and z to z bar and subtract
them what you're going to get left is a
delta z bar a complex conjugate of delta
z
and this equals
the limit
as delta z goes to 0
of
delta x
minus delta y i
over delta x plus delta y
i
good
so the derivative df dz is the
infinitesimal rate of change of f when i
vary delta z
and if you literally plug in z plus
delta z and z into this complex
conjugate function f and cancel them out
just do that on a piece of paper pause
the video and do that you'll see that
the top is going to be delta z bar
and the bottom is just delta z and we're
going to take the limit as delta z goes
to zero and it's equal to this quantity
here okay where you know delta x is how
much i vary in the x direction delta y
is how much i vary in the y direction
but this is where it gets really weird
is that this
derivative is totally different
if i take delta z
infinitesimal in the real direction
versus if i approach infinitesimal
changes in the y or the imaginary
direction so that's what i'm going to
show you here
okay so and let me just define so we're
going to you know let
delta
z equal delta x plus i delta y
that's what we define delta z here delta
x plus i delta y
and
delta z bar equals delta x minus i
delta y that's what we have on the
numerator okay
so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to look at this function as we
approach this derivative as as we take
this delta z goes to zero in different
directions okay and so um
essentially this delta z
i could i'm just going to draw a picture
here actually i think this is going to
make it a lot clearer
so this is the real part
this is the imaginary part let's say
that my point z
is right here at the middle
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna look
at case one
where i take
delta x goes to zero so i'm gonna i'm
gonna start on the on the real axis and
approach as delta x goes to zero
and then case 2
i'm going to freeze
the real part to 0 and i'm going to take
the limit as delta y goes to 0. and for
the derivative to make sense those two
limits should be the same thing okay so
regardless of of how i approach delta c
goes to zero this derivative should be
the same thing no matter what direction
i approach
uh delta z equals zero okay and so if we
if we write this out so if we say you
know um
let's say uh
[Music]
approach you know approach uh delta z
goes to zero
from real axis
from the real
axis
which means delta y starts out being
zero and then i take the limit as delta
x goes to zero
this is case one
then that means the limit this
expression becomes limit as delta x goes
to zero
of
delta x over delta x that equals plus
one
plus one okay so the derivative of this
function if i you know started with
delta y zero and i take the limit as
delta x goes to zero i approach from
this this direction in case one
my limit equals one so so this in case
one this directional derivative is equal
to one
let's look at case 2 when i approach in
the imaginary direction
case 2 when i approach
sorry squeaky when i approach
delta z equals 0 from
from the imaginary axis
so i start off with delta x equals zero
and i take the limit of delta y goes to
zero
now i have limit
delta y goes to zero and now remember
delta x starts at zero and i'm taking
the limit of delta y goes to zero but
here i have
minus delta y i
over plus
delta y i
and if i take the limit as y goes to
zero of this
i get minus 1.
the i's cancel and the delta y's cancel
and i get a minus 1.
and so this is super duper weird okay
this function the
complex conjugate of z the function f of
z equals z bar
does not have a well-defined derivative
it does not have a derivative that is
independent of the path of approach the
delta z goes to zero so we know that
this is the definition of a derivative
that the limit uh as you know my
infinite decimal change goes to zero
of the change in f over that change in z
but because these complex functions have
a real part and an imaginary part i can
take that limit this this derivative
limit i can take that limit approaching
from the you know delta x direction or
from the delta y direction i can
approach from any other angle and i'll
get different derivatives that's also
super weird i can approach from other
directions it's just that these are the
easy ones to compute
and because of the way that this complex
conjugate function works if i approach
from the delta x direction i get plus
one derivative if i approach from the
imaginary or the delta y direction i get
a minus one derivative so this is not a
so this function does not have a
well-defined derivative that exists at
every z like it's which one is it this
doesn't have a derivative it depends on
the path so this is an ill-defined
expression here this is you know
multi-valued it doesn't exist
so this is a weird function that's not
analytic and calculus is difficult
because now the derivatives i take
depend on the path i'm taking okay and
so it doesn't have just an f prime of z
i can't write df dz
i have to specify which direction i'm
taking that derivative i need to i can
only specify directional derivatives for
this function
good
so that is a neat
and kind of intuitive example of what
can go wrong in the complex plane so
this is a non-analytic function
and so now i'm going to revisit what
does it mean for a function to actually
be analytic so these are some conditions
for a function to be analytic
now we're going to start deriving what
are the outcomes what are the kind of
implications of that and i will conclude
by giving you some canonical examples of
functions that yes they are analytic and
some canonical examples of functions
that know they are not analytic okay
and i'm inclined i'm almost feeling like
i should just tell you some examples of
functions that are analytic first maybe
that's what i'll do
uh and i'll do those in blue
so i'll just do some functions that yes
indeed they are analytic so analytic
functions
analytic f of z
would be things like
any polynomial
so polynomials
z to the n for integer n for you know um
n equals one two three dot dot dot okay
not for n equals one half or one third
or one quarter because those are not
single valued polynomials monomials uh
you know sums of monomials polynomials
things like that
those are in fact analytic functions uh
yes indeed they are analytic maybe at
the very end of this video if i remember
i'll just take the polynomial z squared
and we'll do this exact same limit and
i'll confirm for you that yes in fact it
satisfies this property that the
derivative does not depend on the
direction so i'll probably put chapters
in this video and you can fast forward
if you want to see me derive that yes z
squared is in fact analytic and that the
directional derivatives equal each other
no matter what direction i come i come
in from
polynomials
other functions that are good ones so
this is kind of one huge class
another big class are uh functions where
the taylor series exists that's that's
kind of a vague way of saying it but i'm
just gonna say functions
um
kind of with
a
taylor series a well-defined convergent
taylor series
and those would be functions like you
know e to the z
or cosine of z
or sine of z we know that these are
convergent functions they have a
convergent taylor series for all points
z in the complex plane
in fact these functions polynomials and
e to the z cosine of z sine of z these
are not just analytic
in some small neighborhood d they're
analytic everywhere in the complex plane
for every single point z you can name
these are analytic at every point which
again i told you in a previous lecture
the name for that in complex analysis
and mathematics is called an entire
function if it's analytic
everywhere okay if you can do calculus
absolutely everywhere
and then actually there's kind of a fun
uh kind of uh two and a half case where
um
it's like platform uh nine and three
quarters
so this is um kind of a halfway case the
log of z
okay the log of z
on its principal branch
uh you know on
principal branch
let's hope this doesn't on its principle
branch so remember this function the
imaginary part
kind of forms this spiral staircase if i
just take the first branch of this thing
that goes from zero to two pi
then that log of z is single valued on
that branch so if i only define the log
of z on that principal branch
then that is actually analytic
everywhere except at z equals zero so
this is analytic
uh for all
z not equal to zero okay so it's
analytic almost everywhere it's not an
entire function it does have this weird
non-analytic point at the origin so if i
do a contour integral around that point
weird things will happen and i'm going
to show you that in this lecture at the
end and in the next lecture
and in probably all of the next five
lectures we're going to talk about you
know this weird that single weird point
where this is not analytic it's very
important but it's analytic almost
everywhere it's analytic on large swaths
of
large domains of the complex plane that
don't encompass that origin so in fact
this place this domain that i drew here
log of z is analytic on that domain if
i'm only considering the principal
branch that goes you know up one flight
of that spiral that infinite spiral
staircase
so these are functions that yes indeed
they are analytic
and now i'll just give you a few
examples of weird functions that are not
analytics so not
uh an uh
lytic
analytic
um
would be things like uh you know z bar
so things like z bar where the
derivative is different at different uh
directions
so anything that has a singularity so
any function that has kind of a
singularity where this you know goes to
negative infinity so any singularity
uh the function is not analytic at a
singularity so things like one over z
are going to give us lots of trouble
uh if i have a cliff if i have like a a
cliff in my complex landscape so you
know i'm from texas and in texas we have
the the lano escarpment in west texas
where if you approach
at this point it kind of drops
off maybe a thousand meters and there's
a cliff so cliffs
are not analytic because the derivative
would be infinite at that cliff and it
would not exist it would not have a
finite derivative at that cliff
okay
the function log if i don't consider it
on this principal branch
is also not analytic because it would be
infinitely valued the function z to the
one half is not analytic because it's
infinite it's not infinitely valued as
two values it's not single valued
cusps also if i have a function that has
a really sharp cusp
and in fact kind of z bar if you you
might actually want to fire up matlab or
python and plot the real and the
imaginary parts and you'll see that this
function is actually a bit cuspy and
that's kind of a weird thing is that
it's cuspy depending on what
you know direction you approach the
function in
uh and kind of my rule of thumb for
non-analytic functions is it tends to be
functions that cannot easily be
represented
as a closed form of z so z to the n is
kind of only written in terms of z and
if i did f prime it would be n z to the
n minus 1. that's like a well-defined
derivative same with e to the z cosine z
sine of z
but z bar can't be defined as a
primitive function of z it can only be
defined in terms of the real and the
imaginary parts of z
same with logarithm actually right we
can't really write log of z as some you
know primitive expansion of z
we need to write in terms of the real
and the imaginary or the magnitude and
the phase of z and so that's kind of
another rule of thumb i use is if my
function can't be written
as a simple function of z but i need the
real and the imaginary parts to specify
this usually those functions are not
analytic okay good
uh and again as a general rule of thumb
if i just randomly pick a complex
function you know
out of a hat
chances are 99.99999
you know percent of the time it's not
going to be an analytic function
the vast majority of functions if i just
randomly generate a function in the
complex plane it's not going to be
analytic so analytic functions are very
very special in math we call this
measure zero they're a measure zero set
in the space of all functions there are
extremely rare special functions
where you can do calculus
good
okay so now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to derive the cauchy riemann
conditions for a function to be analytic
and this is in terms of partial
derivatives it's an extremely powerful
expression
in math and it ties these complex
functions complex functions to partial
derivatives it's one of the most
important uh
conditions or relationships in all of
complex analysis it's kind of one of the
cornerstones of complex analysis so this
is super important okay so the koshi
riemann conditions okay so for a
function to be analytic
we need for its derivative to be the
same no matter what direction i approach
that derivative okay so i'm just going
to write this out for a function to be
analytic
for a function
to be analytic
for a function to be analytic the
derivative must be the same
uh from the two paths taken on the real
an imaginary axis for a function of
analytic
the derivative
must
be
the
same
for
the two
paths on the real
and imaginary
axes kind of what i drew down here the
if i take my derivative and the delta x
goes to zero direction or the delta y
goes to zero direction those have to be
equal
now this uh
you would need to do some proof
this is a theorem you would need to
prove that theorem that if this is true
if these are equal on the real and the
imaginary axes then it's real from any
approach angle for any way that i could
possibly approach delta z goes to zero
if the delta x limit equals the delta y
limit
then
this is true for any
approach
angle delta z goes to zero that's
something you would need to prove
i'm just going to we're going to say if
that's true then this function is
analytic that's kind of the koshi
riemann hypothesis
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to define our um
you know f of z equals it has a real
part u of x comma y
and an imaginary part i of v of x comma
y
where you know of course z equals x plus
i y okay so this is going to be the
function we're going to take the
derivative of it has a real part and an
imaginary part
and this is the z that we're going to
take the infinitesimal limit of delta z
goes to zero okay which means we're
going to take delta x goes to zero delta
y goes to zero and we're going to
kind of derive what conditions have to
be true
and i'm going to give myself a little
room for my head
so uh df dz
again exactly like what we wrote down
here
is the limit
as delta x goes to zero and delta y goes
to zero that's the same as saying delta
z goes to zero both of these have to go
to zero they could start at zero as in
these two cases or they could start both
non-zero and go to zero any way we like
of
delta u
well let's say delta u it could be of
course it's delta u of x comma y but
let's just say delta u
delta u
plus
i
delta v
divided by delta x plus i
delta
y
again you can
pause the video and you know actually
plug in x plus delta x y plus delta y
you know v of x plus delta x y plus
delta y
and you know expand that out in a first
order taylor series and and
you know cancel out the f of you know
like the the terms that are not plus
delta z and this is what you're going to
be left with so you can expand that out
in a taylor series f of z plus delta z
expand that out subtract f of z and this
is what you're going to be left with up
to first order and we're going to again
divide by delta z okay so you can pause
and verify that this is what you get
when you plug this into this expression
and use the taylor series
and
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take this and again we're going
to take it approaching from the real
axis from the delta x goes to zero
direction and from the imaginary axis
from the delta y
goes to zero axis and those have to be
equal for this to be an analytic
function so kind of you know approach
one again is kind of on the real axis
which is the
delta y starts out being equal to zero
and we say df
dz equals limit
as delta x goes to zero
delta y was already zero because we're
starting on the real axis delta x goes
to zero the limit
of
delta u plus i delta v over delta x
now this is kind of fun
because we froze y equals zero delta y
equals zero and we're approaching on the
real axis
this derivative here is actually a
partial derivative the limit is as delta
x goes to zero for y frozen
of delta u over delta x that's the
partial of u with respect to x
so this is um
partial u partial x
plus i
partial v
partial x this is super important uh so
i'm going to put a little you know i'm
going to well maybe i'll bracket that in
a minute this is super important so if i
take the derivative on the real axis
of this function i get partial u partial
x plus i partial v partial x for
whatever u and v happen to be this is
going to be what that derivative is
in fact you can verify you know here f
of z u is x and v is minus y
and so you can actually compute what
these are if you like
and now we're going to compute what is
the derivative if i approached on the
imaginary axis if i froze delta x equals
zero so now what we're going to do is
we're going to approach on the imaginary
axis as if delta x was frozen at zero
and so d f d
z equals limit as delta y goes to zero
now delta y goes to zero
of delta u plus i delta v over now we
have an i
delta y
okay good and these two expressions are
going to have to be equal for that
function to be analytic so we're going
to use we're going to take these and set
them equal to each other and derive a
set of conditions that has to be true
for that function to be analytic that's
where we're going with this
and now you kind of see this funny thing
that's going to happen because i'm
dividing by i
if you like i can multiply top and
bottom by uh let's say
i times i
and um
if i multiply top and bottom by i times
i i'm going to get some pluses and some
minuses and some weird stuff i'll just
write down what happens so i'm going to
get you know this is going to be a
partial u partial y so that's a partial
u partial y but it has an i out front
here i times
i'm going to
i don't want to like confuse everybody
i'm going to multiply each
top and bottom by i
and so this becomes a minus 1 so this is
a minus
and here
this
i delta u
becomes i delta u and this i times i
delta v becomes minus
delta v
so i have i
delta u minus delta v
that's what happens when i divide by i
apparently okay remember because limit
the delta y had an i out front and so
now if i take the partial derivatives
the real thing is minus partial v over
minus partial y that's just partial
v
partial y
and the imaginary part is going to be
again
minus
i
partial u partial y partial u partial y
okay
so that was a lot again what we're
trying to do is we're trying to uh
essentially we showed the example of
what weird thing can happen when you
approach from different directions and
have a non-analytic function when they
don't equal so we're trying to derive
conditions for what has to be true for
the real and imaginary part of my
function
for these two directional derivatives to
be equal to each other and the two
directional derivatives if i approach on
the real or the imaginary axis are these
two partial derivatives of u and v
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to equate the real parts of
these those have to be equal
and also the imaginary parts also have
to be equal and these are going to give
me my two koshy riemann conditions
so for my function to be analytic i need
partial u partial x
to equal partial v
partial y that definitely
has to be true
and
i need
partial v partial x
or let's say you know partial uh yeah
partial
partial u partial y
to equal minus
partial v
partial x
these are my two koshi
riemann conditions super duper important
koshi
some people uh think it's couchy it's
and
riman uh
and how many m's and rs does riemann
have re man
let's say it's riemann i think there's
probably two m's i'll just put another
one there riemann okay
the koshi riemann conditions so riemann
was gauss's student i think um very very
very bright geometer
koshi was probably one of the most
influential people in making complex
numbers real and concrete for us humans
along with euler so remember before
koshi and before euler people thought
that imaginary numbers were just some
useful computational trick but they
didn't really mean anything they weren't
real
and koshi helped to solidify that
complex numbers and complex functions
are actually you know essential parts of
reality they are solutions of physics
they are real you know concrete objects
and this is one of the most important
conditions in all of mathematics are
called the cauchy riemann conditions
if
the real part u of my function and the
imaginary part v of my function satisfy
these two conditions
what that means is that my derivative
exists and will be finite regardless of
what approach i take this delta z goes
to zero if i go in the real axis or the
imaginary axis if these two conditions
are true then these two expressions will
be equal and and my dfdz is well defined
with without having to specify what
direction i took that derivative in so
this is a huge deal okay huge huge deal
the koshi riemann conditions are
necessary and sufficient well they're
necessary conditions for a function to
be analytic
and if my function is single valued
um you know and these partials exist
then they're also sufficient conditions
very very important
okay so where is this going um so that
that's kind of it we um you know we're
talking about complex functions
uh that we can do calculus on they're
called analytic and they have these
properties basically f prime of z exists
and is well defined regardless of what
direction i take that derivative in
these koshi riemann conditions have to
be true for my derivative to be
independent of the path i take dz to 0
on and that is necessary and sufficient
to have a well-defined derivative so
that i can do calculus functions like
polynomials exponentials cosines and
sines and even the logarithm on its
principal branch away from the origin
are examples of analytic functions
weird functions like the complex
conjugate or singular you know points at
a singularity or cliffs or cusps are
typically not analytic functions
and why do we care about these analytic
functions what do they allow us to do so
analytic functions are super neat
because analytic functions
essentially what i'm going to show in
the next lecture very very important
lecture
is that if the function is analytic if f
of z is analytic then the real part and
the imaginary part solve laplace's
equation then uh del squared u equals
zero and del squared v equals zero
so these analytic functions the real and
the imaginary part solve the laplace
partial differential equation these are
called harmonic functions the real and
imaginary part
of an analytic function are called
harmonic functions these are harmonic
and they're harmonic because they're the
solutions you know of guitar string
waves and and sound waves and all of the
physics that you're used to
uh you know that involve kind of partial
differential equations the basis
functions that we use to represent all
solutions of you know simple linear pds
that we're familiar with are these
harmonic functions like sines and
cosines and things like that the fourier
series are harmonic functions
that are the real and the imaginary part
of complex valued analytic functions
that happen to solve laplace's equation
so that's super duper important
and before computers this is important
before computers we had to solve these
pdes using by hand solutions pulled from
the real and the imaginary part of
complex functions so if you go back in
time 50 years complex analysis was not a
two week boot camp on youtube
it was a full semester course that you
took it was a 15-week course to get so
good at dealing with these functions
that you could actually solve really
hairy gnarly pdes by hand
okay
and then the last thing i'll show you is
that if a function is analytic there are
some really nice properties of
you know solving closed contour
integrals of f of z dz over a closed
contour that's inside this domain
that will equal zero so that's a really
really important property of analytic
functions is that it's really also easy
to integrate them over closed loop just
like we have conservative functions in
physics um
functions that conserve energy like the
potential function the gravitational
potential or the electrostatic potential
hint solutions of laplace's equation
uh if i you know if i take a
frictionless roller coaster and i go
around that roller coaster and i end up
where i started i have neither gained
nor lost any energy and that's kind of
this this generalization that all of
these closed contour integrals
inside of an analytic domain of an
analytic function will add up to zero
they're kind of conservative functions
uh okay that was a huge amount you'll
probably have to you know go through
parts of this again if you really want
to master this this is not trivial stuff
if you want i'm going to probably erase
this in fast forward and show you that z
squared is in fact analytic
but this is kind of the end of the video
so in the next video i'm going to show
you that if my function is analytic it
does solve laplace's equation very very
important all right thank you
okay so right now i'm going to
show you that the polynomial z squared
is analytic
because it is single valued
and because its derivative f prime
exists regardless of the direction that
i take delta z goes to zero okay
um i erased the board i actually tried
to do this
and got myself completely stuck these
things are not always obvious or easy
so i get stuck all the time doing this
kind of stuff
maybe i'll leave that uh part in and you
will have just seen me fast forward
through scratching my beard uh for about
five minutes but it's actually pretty
simple what i'm going to do is we're
going to take the function f of z equals
z squared again this is a single valued
function there's only if if i pick a
specific z there's only one number z
squared
unlike z to the one half which has two
values z squared has one value so it's
single valued and what we're basically
going to do is we're going to compute
uh we're basically going to show that
the koshi riemann conditions hold so
that the derivative along the real axis
and the derivative along the imaginary
axis are equal to each other
uh good so f z
f of z
equals z squared
and i'm going to write this out in the
real part plus the imaginary part so
this equals uh
you know it's like x plus i y quantity
squared so the real part's going to be
an x squared plus an i y quantity
squared which is minus y squared that's
the real part
plus i times uh you know xy plus yx so
that's i times
2xy
and so this is
my real function u
and this is my imaginary function v good
and i think what i'm going to do because
we know
you know if we approach on the real axis
then the derivative is equal to this sum
of partials and if we approach on the
imaginary axis the derivative is equal
to this sum of partials i'm just going
to compute these two partials and
confirm that they're equal to each other
okay so along path one
if i go on the real axis
the real axis path of delta x goes to
zero
then df dz
uh which is essentially df you know the
limit of delta f over delta x
this is going to equal partial u partial
x partial u partial x
plus i partial v partial
y and partial u partial x is 2x
plus i
and partial v partial y is again 2
2x correct
2x
um
did i do that right
oh well i'm stupid this is partial v
partial x sorry i'm not stupid no one
and like when you make a mistake you're
not stupid it was a stupid mistake
this is not partial v partial y here uh
it's an obvious mistake dumb mistakes
are the best mistakes because they're
easily fixed okay that's what i always
tell my students when they you know
finally found a bug in their code and
they feel you know like it was the
simplest mistake and they've been stuck
on it for two weeks those are the best
kinds of mistakes because they're so
easy to fix okay so
dumb mistakes are the best mistakes
this wasn't partial v partial y it's
partial v partial x
and partial v partial x if i take the
derivative i get a 2y that is more like
what i'm looking for
this becomes a 2y
and 2x plus i2y equals 2 x plus i y
which is 2
z beautiful okay that's what i expect my
derivative to be i expect my derivative
f prime of z
intuitively to be 2z that's what we
expect from regular calculus
so that's true when i do this way now
let's try it on the imaginary axis
image
axis okay and i think it's important for
you to see me make mistakes because i
mean i make mistakes all the time when i
do this live for my students sometimes i
actually
prepare only a certain amount so that
they can see you know how you derive
things on the spot and reason on the
spot because it's like too easy to think
that um you know your instructors just
know everything and they remember
everything and they always can solve the
answer
i mean that's probably not the case okay
we all make mistakes and we all have to
be catching ourselves constantly
so now if we compute this on the
imaginary axis we have dfd
uh z equals this is just a a straight
line d this is a total derivative df dz
it equals
partial v partial y
minus i partial
u partial y
okay good
partial v partial y is 2x
good
minus
i
partial u partial y is a minus 2y
so that's a minus 2 y and again 2x plus
i2i is just 2z
so essentially what this shows
is that because these two equal each
other this derivative this function f of
z equals z squared the derivative is 2z
regardless of what direction i take it
in the complex plane
now if you want to get really you know
good at this and you you have 30 minutes
to do this on your own i would recommend
you know we just took the derivative in
the real direction we just took the
derivative in the imaginary direction
confirm for yourself that if you take
the derivative derivative in you know
the
this direction of like delta x equals
delta y goes to zero or in this
direction those also equal to z it's a
little bit hairy you're probably gonna
have to taylor series expand this thing
and keep track of a bunch more stuff
but it definitely is true and that's
kind of how you would prove that this
kosher riemann condition uh
you know
that the real and the imaginary
direction derivatives equal each other
is
necessary and sufficient that the
directions will you know that the
derivative is well defined for any
direction delta x and delta y go to zero
for any path i take where delta x and
delta y go to zero they're all going to
equal each other if these two conditions
are true
okay so
next lecture we're going to prove that
the real and imaginary parts of these
analytic functions are solutions of
laplace's equation called harmonic
functions and we're going to derive some
kind of important consequences of that
all right stay tuned thank you